58 years ago today work began on the
construction of the Berlin Wall the
barrier was intended to stem the
population drain from communist East
Germany to West Berlin and West Germany
the wall formalised West Berlin's
situation as an island in otherwise
communist territory now the Enclave is
now surrounded by more than 150
kilometers of massive fortifications yet
West Berlin remained a magnet for those
wanting to escape East Germany at least
136 people were killed trying to get
across the Berlin Wall in total more
than 600 people were killed trying to
flee East Germany the Berlin wall it
stood for 28 years until 1989 that
famous date when a series of mass
protests set off a chain of events that
ultimately led to the opening of the
frontier and the end of communism in
Central and Eastern Europe during that
time dissidents activists in East and
West Germany they helped smuggle
thousands of people across the inner
German border
our reporter Christina Kufner caught up
with one of them the best thing about
jail Hartmann Victor says was being let
out of his cell once a day to walk
around inside a large wire cage as a
young man he was held for months in a
detention center run by the East German
secret police the Stasi for trying to
flee the country and for aiding others
in their attempts to escape yamaxanadu
homeland they didn't abuse us physically
they called it a corrosion it was a
method they used to try and grind us
down through hyper control isolation
disinformation
I spent the worst 11 months of my life
here after a while you start to longed
to be sentenced Victor never accepted
life on to the East German regime and
tried to flee for the first time by
train when he was just 18 he was
arrested and put behind bars
when building began on the Berlin Wall
on the 13th of August 1961 he knew he
had to escape he saw how brutally the
regime was cracking down on dissenters
mentioned as a young person at some
point you have to ask yourself how long
am I going to play this charade how long
can I take it or do i want to cooperate
with them find myself a little niche as
long as you're still studying you have
to acknowledge this craft in every essay
there had to be a commitment to
socialism and if you needed good marks
you just wrote that rubbish down a short
time later later attempted to escape
again he swam across a border River on
the edge of Berlin and made it to
freedom he was in the water for four
hours before he finally managed to get
through a barbed wire fence and onto the
shore on the western side on the eastern
side he would have been shot I had a
guardian angel that light I knew there
were alarms of the bridge in the
Twilight I saw a thin piece of wire
stretched from bridge post to bridge
post if I had touched it it would have
gone off and they would have immediately
fired shots because a faulty frozen
dozens of people died in this way along
the Berlin Wall
it's still not clear just how many the
regime ruthlessly punished anyone who
tried to flee nevertheless I wish to
continue to help more than thirty people
escape by smuggling them into West
Germany in the boot of his car he was
caught again and spent five years in
prison before he was bought out by the
West German government the 71 year old
now gives tours in his former prison he
thinks young people should learn that
East Germany was a totalitarian state
Mark DeRosa one mentioned you can see
the young people are aware and
interested that's why I do this out of a
sense of eviction I'll always be like
that before I am done bat stealing has
helped Hartmut Victor overcome the
brutality of the Stasi now he's able to
tell the story as one of those who paid
a price for wanting freedom
and I am joined now here in the studio
by axel Klaus Maia director of the
Berlin Wall memorial welcome to the
program and thank you for being with us
on this anniversary let's really start
from the very beginning remind us why
the wall was built to begin with well
there was the enormous pressure on these
German regimes in so many people escaped
the wall Germany as you know was divided
in 45 and especially during after 49 and
between the two German states were
founded and then between 1949 and the
actual date of the wall 1961 about a six
of the entire population had fled the
country and in that respect the
government or the regime was under
pressure and so apparently it saw as the
last exit at last a possibility to stop
people from escaping building a wall in
the center of Berlin since the inner
German border had been sealed off in
1952 already and it was really more than
just one wall was it wasn't it tell us a
little bit more about the fortification
and the area really surrounding it as
well it surrounded the entire West
Berlin so it was approximately a hundred
miles 155 kilometres and it was not I
mean the term the wall is actually
incorrect because it was a whole
sequence of obstacles a sequence of
different walls of perimeter defense but
also an electrical signal fence and a
watchtower a vehicle ditch and all of
this and of course as the actual and the
most dangerous part of it were the
border guards said after 1970 approached
1971-72 approximately 12,000 border
guards were on permanent duty around
West Berlin so only around West Berlin
of course the inner German border was
also protected and it was approximately
12,000 border guards at any given time
and yet people tried to escape some of
them successfully some of them you know
their attempts actually
ended up fatally they were killed do you
think that we will never ever know just
how many people tried to cross well we
have relatively reliable figures we know
that in Berlin alone we have 5000 people
that made it through the border
fortifications we are generally talking
about 50,000 people that crossed the
border but on the inner German border
and and in Berlin but of course the
people also found other ways to escape
so for example there we know of people
that escaped through third countries
like Romania or former Yugoslavia we
know of people who even crossed via
China so East Germans entered the West
German Embassy in Beijing for example
and then were flown out into the West so
it was a very long way from East Berlin
into the West via Beijing we have this
phenomena we have to say also is is that
not not everyone thinks that things were
all that bad in the former East in fact
there's there's a bit of nostalgia
amongst some sort of a longing for the
way that things used to be what do you
say to that well it is certainly a
phenomena that has been referred to many
times over the last thirty years and I
think there's nostalgia and it was
called Australia of mixed with eat with
the east in the German term certainly
something about when things change
abruptly when when there are very fast
changing movements and then all of a
sudden for example the entire political
system that surrounded you and this is
understandable but I do believe that
it's a bit over exaggerated because a
lot of people really very much value the
new Germany
and the majority of former East Germans
do value the new democratic Germany
thank you so much for joining us to
speak on this anniversary of the
beginning of building of the Berlin Wall
axl Klaus Meyer director of the Berlin
Wall memorial we appreciate you very
much